[Música]
el 2 de julio de 2018 los 80 volcanes de
auvernia se convirtieron en una de las
maravillas de la unesco desde entonces
toda una población se encarga de
preservar este patrimonio invaluable
esa es la misión de estos dos
guardaparques trabajan en el lugar donde
se encuentra la cadena de los pool
[Música]
el parque de los volcanes abarca
alrededor de cuatrocientas mil hectáreas
la cadena de los pools tiene 13.000
hectáreas si tomamos en cuenta el
patrimonio mundial son 40 mil hectáreas
es solo un pequeño pedazo estamos aquí
para tratar de preservar la naturaleza
de la manera más intacta posible y para
preservar estos territorios todavía
salvajes los guardaparques registran
todos los insectos que se encuentran
aquí
me espera
está debajo de la hoja creo que ahí está
ahí
la tengo si su misión del día es
delicada salieron a cazar además esta no
es la misma es negra hormigas la siesta
que tengo es una roja no los
guardaparques realizan un inventario de
las especies presentes en el sector
y para atraerlas tienen una técnica
infalible
tenemos un pequeño papel blanco más o
menos de un centímetro cuadrado
y ponemos paté y después miel para
atraer a las hormigas como si fuera un
picnic es un festín para las hormigas si
es un festín pero de corta duración
porque después van a morir
vamos a meterlas en alcohol y las
observaremos con binoculares durante el
invierno
estudiar y explorar lo infinitamente
pequeño de esos espacios para
protegerlos mejor pero también
sensibilizar a los 500.000 turistas que
cada año recorren este territorio
tenemos la obligación de protegerlo es
decir de mantenerlo en buen estado que
no se deteriore que no haya
construcciones hoteleras que crezcan
como maleza por todas partes favorecer
el agostadero favorecer el pastoreo es
necesario que podamos acondicionar este
turismo a la escala humana conservar un
turismo a escala humana es también un
reto de seguridad los 80 volcanes de
auvernia de los cuales los más antiguos
surgieron hace 95 mil años están
inactivos por ahora pero en las entrañas
de la tierra la temperatura sigue
subiendo probablemente algunos magmas
puedan subir hasta la superficie y hacer
reacciones volcánicas lo que no sabemos
es cuándo se va a producir podría
producirse mañana podría producirse
dentro de diez años dentro de cien años
dentro de mil años todavía están vivos
están dormidos están en reposo pero no
están matando más allá del espectacular
paisaje que ofrecen las increíbles
propiedades de las rocas
canicas hacen felices a los artesanos de
la región
en los alrededores de clermont ferrand
este taller moldea la lava esmaltado
un trabajo de orfebrería que consiste en
cocinar esta piedra de magma durante
varias horas en estos enormes hornos a
980 grados
esto está bien perfecto impecable yo
sigo siendo como un niño para mí la
apertura del horno siempre ha sido
importante con el calor que sale de
golpe todavía a 130 grados y que te
atrapa uno puede ver realmente una pieza
terminada que sigue caliente
hoy en día más de la mitad de los
negocios de la empresa se realizan a
nivel internacional los guéridon es para
el restaurante parís listo un logro que
le debe mucho a la unesco para el hotel
samba también se va es una carta
complementaria que podemos mostrarle a
nuestros clientes explicándoles que hoy
en día les podemos ofrecer lava
esmaltada y que proviene de auvernia
patrimonio mundial de la unesco en
francia
la explotación de los recursos de la
cadena de los pool está reglamentada
para no dañar los suelos de los bosques
los leñadores han recurrido a una
solución original
el transporte de madera a caballo
cortan y sacan los árboles con caballos
de tiro
y supervisar esta labor hace parte de
las múltiples misiones de los
guardaparques
terminaremos esta noche debemos tener 25
aquí con los 4 caballos 30 entonces está
bien está bien con los caballos es muy
manejable vamos por un árbol a la
derecha por un árbol a la izquierda y
regresamos y exhalando entre los árboles
el resto se afecta muy poco
entonces el bosque sufre menos exacto
así es y se conserva para el futuro y
como sería con la máquina bueno un poco
menos
[Música]
desde 1977 con sus 400.000 hectáreas el
parque natural de los volcanes de
auvernia constituye el conjunto
volcánico más grande de europa
[Música]